thank you for listening to another
episode of a handsome Rambler podcast we
had a good time on this one talking to
the Lucas brothers that's when I can't
tell them apart I've known them close to
10 years it's embarrassing
let's get over it I want to be on tour a
little bit September 14 15 4 16th I'll
be in Camden New Jersey with Lauryn Hill
and Nas and Bristol Virginia with Lauryn
Hill and Nuys and September 16th it's
just me my goddamn self
tawny trim on the wheels it's gonna be a
good time get tickets a Hannibal Buress
com
if you're able to donate to victims of
Hurricane Harvey and Irma donates the
Houston Food Bank and other charities
that look legit and like they're not
stealing money do it alright check out
that later
[Music]
Lucas brothers
I feel like your heroin making a
comeback super come back yup you know
some heroin is like it came back alright
yeah offer it to you know unless they
said in a week oh [ __ ] you talk about it
walked away passed on a drug addict bro
Oh got you that's mine that's mine you
in do it you and do a drug addict rule
if it was a guy like that uh who like
you know with a full-time [ __ ] ballers
oh no I mean hard drugs but still still
function who Ryan Gosling in that one
movie he was a teacher what he was doing
cracking yeah that type of crack at it
oh yeah pills over oh yeah pills you
know you know what it is about pills
that I mean obviously pills dangerous
and can be abused
but is the method yeah take them same
way you take vitamins like you look fine
with other I just took fish oil you just
took seven vicodin same thing though
let's go out have you done the tac pills
great come on you know what I like I
want they come on so chill there yeah
one day hit you forgot that you took
home yep yeah oh [ __ ] yeah I'm all
giggly and happy absolutely no we had I
swear by
yeah he's worried about Al Jackson hit
me up he's in Denver he said I'm
grabbing you some cuz I I think I was
I've got some and left and with it but
yeah straddles nah native native native
roots my homie Chris yeah he run he will
used to remember when we did a promo
video with them nowhere yeah they like
there were the ones that first came up
with that sex lube I was called for eeeh
[ __ ] insane it's like a chain they're
gonna get up in Cali they're killing it
killing it they get like they get
endorsements from like rappers and [ __ ]
uh how far away do you think we are from
full-on legalization and you know in the
United States yeah yeah you'll see it
yeah
full legalization yeah forget to how
many spaces it now 20 is I mean I know
some medical and yeah so I wonder what
what we need to get to yeah because
there's what is it
Khalid okay Washington Colorado
Oh Michigan Michigan yeah they have what
medical or no that's right great
oh well shickens record recreational I
believe no we're in the south I don't
think Nevada oh yeah South labs yeah DC
DC aren't they recreation a right now
right there medical they got some weird
loopholes dole for senators and no it's
supposed to be recreational but there's
like weird loopholes like where they're
like residents will I do
it's always the broke city's
Mississippian the southeast Mississippi
is gonna be the fiftieth yeah cuz some
of them other ones got new and then a
big as where it so they get that maybe
we the most they do calm down more than
they need Jesus I feel bad because I
don't go visit my grandmother cuz it's
Mississippi yeah - and isn't that it's
not even I mean on it's only two have
you done have you
I've played Hattiesburg a few times but
that's mostly because of his proximity
to New Orleans
oh it's the route dear good it's a good
tag right yeah I've I've worked it on
the way to New Orleans and then
sometimes I just been in New Orleans and
I pop to Hattiesburg do a show and then
just come at me I would have yeah click
crap yeah you don't go see your
grandmother when you I don't know it's a
it's a super small town call none of
your business Mississippi my is no
grocery store no real grocery store but
there's a there's a small convenience
store and that's where you get I mean if
you wanted to really do grocery shop you
had to go about 13 miles citizen belzoni
which is slightly less small and
terrible yeah still that and what she
there in the 60s she's been there I mean
my mom was born in 54 mmm
so much she's been down at four but most
of my mom's siblings moved up to Chicago
in 60 70s and [ __ ] yeah but it's I gotta
get down there never state I think about
it know that laughs and everything yeah
it's uh a couple of rappers from
Mississippi right Big KRIT
[Music]
Rachel Mississippi yeah oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
mistaken Tupelo Mississippi River yeah
crit who else yellow wool from Alabama
Alabama uh create reps from Mississippi
to any ballplayers Mississippi probably
probably a bunch but it's just yeah they
just say yes see I [ __ ] with Birmingham
Alabama always remember I always have a
good time I found was from Eufaula
Alabama yeah uh-oh
how far is that from Birmingham about
two hours yeah Horace [ __ ] it's not a
good time
no man is decrepit the scary especially
as a [ __ ] and I'm not even Chinese
but is a video I saw about and it kind
of made me think about the town my
family's from about the row of Koreans
coming into Mississippi into the Delta
which I SOLAS in and he started these
stores and that's where black people
bought food cuz why people wouldn't let
black people come into the store so
Koreans came in darling and they but
then they didn't uh they were still they
were racist to sound that's the classic
Korean story Koreans in America it's
like hey these white people want to [ __ ]
with these black people so we'll go in
there and get that money yeah but we'll
still be racist but again in money does
that but not heavily racist just a
distance just a code yet not racist but
you won't be coming over during uh for
the barbecue I mean I got it let me
growing up in Chicago like I
a lot of relatives that I got businesses
in the hood yeah if I could record
stores yeah doors whatever beauty supply
stores
yeah beauty supply like my uncles aunts
were never scared they were scared areas
like you know going out to work gonna
get our money and what it is yeah yeah
yeah black people get black businesses
and in the city's house that is not
getting capital like that I don't know
what it is yeah I didn't wake up here to
give loans from banks the loans or
Koreans you know what it was it was
Church because they would loan each
other money like the Korean community
would get together with a church would
be like a big front not a front I mean
they were Jesus we all love each other
all right now is talk busier than no
interest everybody that's how the Korean
community always work together you know
it's like that's how the Jewish did it
exactly yeah and the church was a major
institution in black communities but why
didn't still it why weren't able to get
this week at all that food it's all
about that food afterwards my photos was
not talked about money
[Laughter]
coffees juice does it got to do it you
sugar
yeah get your rush [ __ ] just enough to
get through the sermon just to get the
sir
the mass was usually by our two hours we
did it I had a side hustle though I
would sell [ __ ] a VHS I would give
VHS pornos and I was so him in the
parking lot words yeah that was my house
yeah yeah like I don't remember that
[ __ ] I would dub be a jazz born and I
was sold to the charts for real yeah get
my hands on something somebody got out
the Playboy channel read your skinemax
once in a while get the heart the heart
shaped like a real [ __ ] like the
penetration Dallas that's not good at
least point at least no like 15 20 maybe
no they do get the titles of everything
or did you rename porn no I wouldn't
label because I was smart my mom's would
be like why you got all these VHS tapes
and I'd be like oh you know it's [ __ ]
Batman yeah Church helped me out
financially hey look I mean you got to
be able to use the institution for
multiple of course yeah I just forgot
it's all the front for money it is out a
friend
yeah but black me we just couldn't
figure it out because they're too long
man I know five hours well well we had
like especially on the west side of
Chicago I'm from lots of barbershops
tons of competition like direct three
door down pipe
why so many barber shops it's a lot of
Barbra Jean did you go to the barber
shop on Saturday do you think maybe
there should be this menu bar besides
like we like good night experience but
it's mostly about when you go to a your
Barbara or whoever cut your hair it's
mostly about the conversation horn
sports tapes you got to do it to
yourself
a woman cuts my hair so it's like but
it's not the same it's not the same for
me
but I still like to catch up you know I
just go to black barber shops
well I've been to black barber salesmen
when I was in college I had a guy cut my
hair that I was living on my floor
he fed everyone on me he was he was not
the best but the [ __ ] had to
give the gap more important exactly as
we would talk and he would just let me
tell you some true life you know he
because he was all the guy senior what
was the gym he's a thief you remember
none of the gyms yeah I remember a
couple of things he said you know it's
like well past the gym zone can't let
the gyms die with you when I was a
freshman man it was a cliche [ __ ] you
know like don't get high on your own
supply those nice to have that
relationship yeah yeah yeah and when
you're waiting around with the other
guys we're all talking - everybody's
talking everyone's have a good time I
got a lot of DJ gigs out of it me go it
was a good time that's all that matters
man not a lot of food in a barbershop
though no
vending machines though machines that
will drink yeah good drinks drink at the
barbershop
yeah yeah I never had a drink in a bar I
know me neither I've fit one of my
barbershops
one time at night there's a few years of
a had a stripper party sounds amazing
we're out of here though
have you got loose hair a lot of things
there's a lot of things that could ruin
yeah party went off without a hitch but
that's a I went to a handful of those as
a teenager and young adults acog oh just
underground yeah stripper parties women
[ __ ] hired a handful of strippers and
it's a house party
but his strippers there and it was some
weird [ __ ] going for it it was his one
that you know I mean it was a stripper
party but you know I mean stripping
don't pay all the bills right so and so
this house had it was into the party was
in the basement but then they had this
space where was I at this party
absolutely not I remember a party like
this in college but anyways oh yeah they
didn't have some of those in Carbondale
- I think you are with me that one night
is that the night that you punched
murder man in the face
no it's not it wasn't that house told
you prints somebody murder man you know
some people would anything I've never
been in a fight
this guy was 350 pounds and his name was
murder man and he punched them what do
you do to me but you know things have to
be done and they need to be made you
know so I was there I pulled them off of
you you
you want dollar not I didn't say you
weren't there saying you weren't the
only one - yeah for him or for you for
you for you or for them this basement
[Music]
you know some people will be [ __ ] the
girls in these little but it was I won't
put him out there as what his he wasn't
my it was this guy in there he was
getting some head or something and the
friend of the person I was with I walked
up this is me well do that's crazy and
then a stole all the CD it was a stack
of CDs at the crib said all of that [ __ ]
and we left that bit yeah opposed to do
that at a youth youth group before
church I do church group yeah yeah
that's the one visit time I remember
doing it yeah that's crazy why did I do
it again it was a race war man there's
about four black people in an Asian kid
and then everyone else was white and we
just had this crazy dodgeball tournament
and it got praise Jesus right after
there's a weird setup but then I think
some I think something happened in that
dodgeball thing and then it boy it like
spilled out into like basketball and
then a big race war fight broke out and
oh yeah yeah a bunch of dudes man reply
straight up a combo one punch then I
walked away yeah he was like oh I do
yeah he just stood there in shock yeah
anything
I don't never punch you in the face I
don't want to [ __ ] up the investment the
face like that plenty of fights younger
we used to go crazy yeah yeah who would
usually be the winner
well it's kind of hard to determine like
we'll be like we'll wrestle for a bit
and then we'll fight and then we'll just
stop fight yeah twins of that weird
connection do you guys do you guys
believe that I'm watching this
documentary on with the particle physics
yeah and they're talking about how like
like the partial wavelength yeah you can
separate the particles but they can
still connect yeah across space and time
yeah so like I think that that happens
with us yeah I'm like a subatomic level
since we do share the same DNA yeah like
for an example give me an example the
explanation is great let me see before
but like I can examine this like when we
were in law school we were set we
separate it yeah but I could like we
would like Collin know like when some
[ __ ] was off yeah
Phil Wynn is off yeah even with him not
being in Detroit I knew some [ __ ] with
all but I could also just be separation
anxiety
you probably have a full materialistic
explanation for why we get sad when
we're apart but it's also somewhat small
so we like to say the word at the same
time we're on stage we might say a word
at the same time it's never time yeah
it's just like sometimes you like we
might share a similar thought which is
crazy because like a thought is not a
actual thing that's worth thinking that
same thing at the same time at the same
time it then you know yeah saying it at
the same time where's our yeah so how
the decision to go to law school you
y'all both decided to go to law school
we said no this one in this one yeah I
was I was in a relationship I was
[ __ ] pussy-whipped and then I decided
to go to a law school that was closer to
my girlfriend he's betrayed do you want
to do yeah you and why you okay betrayed
I wanted to live in New York but
harborough's yeah you know 20 22 and
yeah thank you but I wasn't even
availing myself at a city I'll go to
Jersey and then travel into New York at
my second year just Kim you from like
the shittiest town in New Jersey taeyang
yeah no it was a [ __ ] you in New
Jersey not a stress factor but not much
besides that one other one like some
Jersey City stuff do you guys have
shitty town we really been Jersey but I
felt there two people but you know what
I mean I say to people with terrible but
also I feel like it some places where
you go there and say this is terrible
yesterday this
some people that are very passionate
yeah about this state but they don't
listen to the stuff today I was given
proper Birmingham this whole time
balance [ __ ] with Birmingham left on
cities yeah fair balanced news was quit
law school at the same time yeah
oh [ __ ] I think you made a decision
first and then I wasn't gonna do it
unless you were gonna come in with me
yeah one of you stayed in law school the
other one didn't yes that dynamic rides
for the rest of your life yeah I would
have been a bum jumped off a bridge by
all right now yeah so so the so the
comedy thing you guys before law school
were already who you guys already into
it or was it like no passively it wasn't
like anything I never thought that it
would be
I had gone to Eastvale you know in New
York yeah and I did that while I was in
my third year of law school and I'll go
to the cellar and watch and [ __ ] but I
never thought that like it would turn
into anything but yeah I I think because
I started doing improv first I was like
let me try that [ __ ] out and I was like
it's too corny man I want to do that the
whole everybody else everybody else was
so corny it made you feel coy it's just
not so I mean yeah it was just coin like
I just didn't feel like the kind of
comedy I wanted to do I felt like it was
a great skill to have but I was just
like I that's just not how I wasn't good
at it either
I was probably projecting a little bit
spend times I've been dancing with a
girl and I feel like I'm alright dance
appearing so bad that I feel like I
can't dance yeah that's why I hate no
that's what a girl can't dance throws me
off yeah the opposite when she's so good
yeah good [ __ ] dad I keep up
I see that as a challenge but how good
do you see like a professional dancer
she's just like oh yeah rhythm yeah
professional no I see I play like I can
only do I'm like a girl I only know how
to two-step so if you got some other
[ __ ] going somewhere you thought the
two-step saw you on our podcast dances
that's thing about me man I deejay
I love watch people dance making them
dance but if you make me go out there
I'm just like I don't got you by
yourself in the room you know here's the
thing like uh dancing to me I always
like I don't get the joy hmm and
happiness out of dancing like everyone
else feels so arbitrary to me like
people are moving around and and and
move in and to me is just like what is
this it doesn't bring me the same kind
of joy where you're kind of like God
you're creating the rhythm and the
people are just receiving the rivers
it's like a so I can't like I don't and
it's not even that because I got DJ
friends who love to dance
yeah it's not I don't know what it is
about dancing that just it feels like
this arbitrary thing to me I don't know
there was that one City though
Pittsburgh yeah but I'm like that I
don't
I can dance but I also can have a great
time just watching and also I can watch
the room better was I like to do I to
see I can watch people approach yeah I
just like to see how it's fun especially
is good music play yeah yeah I don't
like it when people having a great time
and then somebody bumps into somebody
and then the fight happens yeah dammit I
hate the fight I was having a good time
and I remember for a while was just like
I had to just not play Waka Flocka
because fights Waka Flocka just for a
while for some reason always caused
violence for them yeah it's not like
that anymore yeah cuz old but before
hard in the paint
all that [ __ ] my to paint definitely
what
attracts yeah that's our gang signs as
they are you know I get I've heard that
about some DJ's with certain songs three
6 mafia to the club date [ __ ]
will feel like they actually have to do
it yeah you still you know even though
it's called to the club up you can
parent like just dance with a girl is
some dance with a girl to that well you
can just jump around with your friends
or drink your drink you don't have to
break [ __ ] where they change the the
lyric yeah yeah no there's just some
certain songs that you know I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna name this DJ's name
because he's still very relevant but DJ
Premier we did on New Year's in Chicago
and he just like he like what right in
the turn-up [ __ ] like you know King
Louie is from Chicago some gangbangers
[ __ ] drill [ __ ] so he went like straight
in the drill [ __ ] like literally like
5-10 minutes in Lewis just the I got
this like mini brawl broke out shirts
are getting but I wonder if is it a good
idea to do it before people get too
drunk ya know people already dressed
down but like he was cool about it he
cut the music of is that I'm man hey
what's your shirt back on yo chill out
looks like that kind of spot and then
they like cleaned it up yeah but like
yeah 5-10 minutes into it
he [ __ ] he just it was so turn he
turned it but he he knew he had that
power to do it yeah yeah he just wanted
to turn up I didn't know there was some
thug ass [ __ ] in there that I
always assumed those will be there oh
yeah oh yeah yeah
Chicago yeah you know y'all ever have
thugs that your comedy shows thugs there
are methods running does probably really
get hyped about seeing twins yeah yeah
we didn't get bullied in a ghetto either
cuz but you make sense to rob two people
get twice the logic Memphis the first
time I saw you guys way back in New York
for no it wasn't that the Knitting
Valley it was just some random gig me
and amber Lucas brothers suck and like
yeah but the first thing that came went
through my head was like what is their
process yeah like yeah it's just like we
wanted to because we want to make our
[ __ ] as natural as possible so it's like
you got to just do it how we normally do
it how we normally talk and but you have
like a physical representation of that
self-regulation you know like do you
ever regulate yourself like you say I'm
not gonna do that you know I had this
joke now that has not been going well
it went well once in Atlanta that's the
worst man and and I've been trying I
tried it a couple times in New York and
it hasn't it's just talking about how
being in a movie trailer or not in the
truck just being in the mood is a boring
process just it's very slow yeah it's a
lot of downtime like this is terrible
Yeah right i I see how Philip Seymour
Hoffman I don't think he did I don't
think he tried heroin for the first time
at a party i that happened doing a for
doing a for our camera turn around in a
trailer he was like let me try out air
when I got a lot of downtime and then it
went from there and so for some reason
at this show at Star Bar in Atlanta it
was a really fun Monday night show host
about it
ratney he's like a good showcase it
killed there you know I did uh Ilana has
been doing some warm-up shows for her
tour in New York and so a lot of glaze I
popped up on her show last week or two
weeks ago did a guest spot of course
crowd goes crazy feels good
settle down I open with that [ __ ] and
[ __ ] just went season I go from being
famous is just like what is he doing in
a isn't Brooklyn yeah but it was I tried
it at the same venue somebody else's
show it was not the same you're getting
very [ __ ] you see I mean I keep a kid
offended people get offended easily out
I think it needs a reword or but enough
about but in New York yeah on a Monday
and in New York but very aware of it is
there an expectation that you know I
haven't heard that one yes sorry I wanna
talk about the self-regulation like you
gotta go through another [ __ ] [ __ ]
get your jokes out there but it's good
sometimes because sometimes you have
ideas that just like are too out there
and you have someone but sometimes you
just want to be experimental sometimes
he probably like no let's go even
further
yeah that's right right yes push it I
think I don't know I already know the
rules man there are no rules I have a
question for you guys
yes what happened to the Lucas the Lucas
moving company show what the Fox
executives disagree with it's real I
didn't think that it had the legs to
really yeah we had to convince a 60 year
old white guy that it was why did you
just move it over the car cuz they they
control the Fox home owned it so they
they wouldn't they weren't willing to
but you guys were willing to take it
somewhere else
yes but then I was just like [ __ ] it man
that show was so [ __ ] good so yes man
D you all that was your first show there
the cartoon yeah Lucas brothers moving
company yeah so funny started out on I
played a mom can't believe you Lucas
brothers caught a case you two are
disgraced I would expect this from your
father blue your massage your mouth
[Music]
probably my favorite character some
people still hit me up about that man
that was a fun that was some it was fun
to see how that came together yeah yeah
there wasn't enough seasons
yeah it should have been like ten more
seas gotta talk to Rupert yeah yeah
[ __ ] deal Rupert Rupert come on man
bring the Lucas brothers what as far as
acting stuff do you guys you know
audition do you know other than what I
do yeah which might be limiting but [ __ ]
it but they have tried to get you to
audition audition work sometimes they
want you to do Sol audition I am
so they'll bring him in first and then
I'm like you know watch me go through
horribly and then I if I can't do this
[Laughter]
you guys often get like booked together
or like asked we only we try to only get
booked together okay so that's the
strategy yeah okay you know not the most
financially sound one but yeah it's like
[ __ ] it man
but that's your thing yeah work together
[Laughter]
way more entertaining it's like a WWE
tag-team they got you got to stick
together can't break up maybe break up
eventually but you get those game what's
the guy's name Dean Martin and Jerry
Lewis they had a good leg
fifteen movie runs just gotta go on a
little runnin you're good 15 this is the
last movies were terrible but I didn't
see any of you don't have to this might
be a hack question but which you are
approach a movie full house style
where is role but you all yes whispering
take breaks smartest thing to do I think
it'd be like some like SAG thing oh yeah
[ __ ] sag if I have a problem with
that yeah no I don't know I mean
sometimes they have a sag rep snooping
around just for I don't know what they'd
be really been looking for but I've been
on is been CEO Dafina three four times
the but I was when when I was working on
his movie it was so it was parsed it was
so tedious and boring on there I was
like mary-kate and Ashley Olsen they had
some thought I was ahead they built a
billion-dollar industry but basically
off of one roll yeah [ __ ] insane jeez
it's really good that were always
confused me he's a kid too
when I was watching the show the credits
would say why got two names yeah but he
said the longest name ever
yeah yeah no no it was the ampersand
that's right was it what the [ __ ] yeah
it's a mary-kate and Ashley Olsen yeah
in the credits do they just do that
because they were kids and they didn't
want that one kid couldn't do why don't
you just have twins in the show [ __ ]
up the story man I mean in cuz then and
what if one of them started acting weird
and you wanna keep thinking oh this is
probably an insurance move like one kids
[ __ ] out
yeah yeah with that's I'd talked about
that on kamisato about that baby the
baby on daddy's home kept on bringing
different like the one baby we'll start
tweaking out get that baby at it next it
was for real they had and they had two
more babies just on deck and then it was
it was for real like how I said it was
the third baby the [ __ ] was just
chill yeah [ __ ] baby at the end of the
day what are you gonna really do it's
not gonna change the move yeah it's a
[ __ ] baby but this is a quiet yeah
hey or but guess what
the mother babies ain't getting no
resolve a dumbass stupid baby cry yeah
you ain't getting none of them they run
daddy's home a lot baby's lost lost out
on some goddamn Starbucks money you guys
so you guys recently moved to LA
straight wait yeah straight from
Brooklyn to LA I feel like that's a
trend yeah going on now right New
Yorkers moving to LA New York is cold
man and [ __ ] I miss it but I think
that the cops are it's too much yes when
we went back a few weeks it felt like
the skate from New York like yeah we had
too many cops it was cold
you don't feel I've been oppressed by
the cops
in the winter yeah and they're very
serious about weed super serious Bo yeah
over some it's New York
yeah why are you so [ __ ] what about we
lookin 80s had a terrible drug problem I
think they're always like scared about
that [ __ ] they're like I don't want I
don't we don't want it to become [ __ ]
a crack epidemic again but it's already
a heroin epidemic so I was like just let
me be legal Denver is the best though
Denver has hands they're simple yeah
they just pulse it in here wait for - I
like today for the dispensaries they
don't like to have more than like for my
cousin s like we don't want you wait
here and you step out when they step out
you come in and you're gonna get great
service you're an explanation yeah they
said there's more there's more
dispensaries in there's Starbucks
oh yeah get some weed lube yeah what
can't they mix Starbucks what are like a
we think that's what we need yep yeah
the combo businesses Taco Bell
dispensary Starbucks is already ahead of
it I bet you there yeah I bet you there
when they legalize it yep we're gonna
have our little we've a so everything
yeah yeah we need to get into that
really business absolutely I'll get
ahead of it in in the state that yep it
looked the slowest in Mississippi
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
this week's episode of the handsome
Rambler is brought to you by five for
club looking good doesn't need to cost a
fortune and five for club is helping the
way men shop for clothing each month
they send you a curated box of two to
three items that are hand-picked to
match the current season and your
individual style they've been helping
men with fashion for 15 years now and
they shipped over a hundred thousand men
every month five four Club will help you
build your wardrobe one month at a time
you get a hundred and twenty dollars
worth clothes for just 60 bucks a month
you can pause or cancel anytime because
there is no commitment so head to five
for club calm and enter promo code
Rambler and they'll give you 50% off
your first month's package and a free
pair of sunglasses that's 50% off your
first package at five for club that
spelled fi ve fo you are club comm enter
the promo code Rambler get those
sunglasses and get that 50% off five for
club comm promo code Rambler holla
[Music]
what type of lawyers we are gonna be if
you were and how far away that y'all
we were so it's three years to get your
law degree I was 2 and 2/3 or 2/3 of
yeah we're almost done basic yeah like a
few weeks so it was more of a choice of
we're not gonna be lawyers we network
it's like a it was more like I want to
get into something creative and I didn't
want to have any like I don't wanna have
a safety net so back yeah I don't want
to [ __ ] do that cuz I feel like
you're gonna there's gonna be a moment
and whatever create a passion that
you're pursuing there's gonna be a
moment of just like crisis go back but
was but what was comedy and whatever
lucrative it at that time oh like most
people who start at the very bottom yeah
yeah figure that [ __ ] out yeah and it
was rough like we had no money we had to
move back in with our mom like this is
terrible
oh you when you go for me and I got the
top law school we got like a job like
eating a veneer like I got to move back
in with my how old were you guys when
had to move back to me before 24 yeah
sorry to do that is rough well but she
was she understand it was he yelling at
y'all all types of ways she didn't get
it she got it like he was supportive he
wanted us to be law school snap out yeah
she was like you dropped out of here and
he dropped out of here it have been
different if y'all wear the same spot
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
she was tweaked and even if she played
it cool she is your mom yeah she has a
higher educated group no she got to use
with high school yeah
so yeah we're the only ones to go to law
school and drop out at the same time the
same time yeah a new way I know and then
she saw our first we did a bringer show
at comics do you mean I quote yeah yeah
is tough to be aggressive you just got
it you know yeah family family a suicide
[ __ ] is you doing
how was how's the reception to the next
expensive is it dope yeah weird because
we didn't have any long from stand up so
I don't think people knew we did stand
up yeah so when you have something like
that and people dig it it's like it's
cool to finally be seen as a stand up
yeah yeah and so now I feel like a
comedian right here like you can do sets
on tonight's show but it's like it's not
the it's not the same it's like you want
to have that long set out there and it
feels great
here's the problem with America mm-hmm
it's income inequality I think that's
the problem I think they need to
restructure how we pay people like
football players they get guaranteed
contracts all right so it'll get a
hundred million dollars but they
guarantee like 40 million I think they
should do that for teachers absolutely
absolutely
[Applause]
that's what that food that's why if we
were able to overthrow the government
and become twin dictators that would be
our first order of business we were
right with we divorce ibly round up all
the teachers yes and we would bring them
to a room like this and it would be like
teachers of America we know you guys
have suffered so we are going to pay you
a hundred million dollars that's right
mm-hmm but we can only guarantee about
twenty thousand I'm waiting to the
marketplace settle down everybody get
these shits of my vagin
yeah I see Game of Thrones yeah I've
been watching we were just talking about
that
yeah earlier I don't I don't watch it
but I watched a couple of the first up
I'm just too far yeah I gotta get either
I gotta get sick it's too many or maybe
maybe that's other stuff I wanna watch
yeah yeah you have a commit a month or
two or three - oh yeah and you got a
really like you got a like when you
commit to that story you got a really
good because there's so much the writing
is not caught up to the show so it's
like right now what they're doing is
Godfather 3 yeah like he's always - I
mean Breaking Bad nailed it but but it's
not based on characters that are
supposed to yeah go somewhere they're
Russian it's like truncated it's like
crazy
we have y'all read The Game of Thrones
books I don't but you could tell you
could you could tell well no I just
I'm just asking just cuz you know when
people read the books is a different
level of passion yeah I'm not never
experienced I've never experienced for
anything by the storyline like it takes
forever for one for one character you to
get from one area to another it's like
this huge journey and all of a sudden
the whole season for this [ __ ]
yeah yeah and in one episode he's there
it's making noises like the first season
so nuanced and like the development is
slow the pacing is good now it's just
like they're rushing - yeah it just
feels it's just they're jumping the
shark there's no there's nothing to go
off with the writing nope yeah it's like
this season is the last one or the next
thing next one the next but they just
ended the they just ended the first half
of the season and they got [ __ ]
milking it yeah
is it already they should ended it yeah
yeah I'm over it man they should have
went out over red woody and haze the way
y'all feel I'm glad old school yeah and
that's but yeah I still I don't I don't
know everybody yeah but is I went to
Wrestlemania though on a whim I was
going from I was in Charlotte hanging
with my cousin and I was gonna have to
go to Miami two days after that and so I
saw some I was there my father saw a
couple people posted about being a
resume today I know mm-hmm you know Mike
Orlando is in between Charlotte and
Miami director so I was like [ __ ] it
I'm gonna go to Wrestlemania yeah what
do you think it's crazy yeah what's
crazy it's a great show yeah and yeah it
was outside take a while right well then
take a retires undertake a retiring yeah
and a long long walk up walk off walked
up his plate amusement that pretty much
the show is the walk up it is but it was
this is on so it was a super extended
long as RAM
[Music]
like I went to smack down a couple last
week that had a short there's a short
what it used to do it yeah yeah the
shorter yeah but the energy is that
walk-ups is just it hypes people up yeah
its production it's what I should talk
and all that but that's how I mean from
what also from watching other musicians
and comedians what's how I built like
the walk-up is there's been so many
times where I'm like I don't [ __ ] with
this musician but I want to see how they
enter I want to see how they come up on
yeah cuz I got all this hype yeah and
everybody loves them but at the end of
the day is you gotta have that Walker
juiced up my walk up I got video package
right I got video package right like
blackout lights video highlights what
would James Brown that's not what these
people paid no no no that's what I
respect you know I'm not a wrestling fan
but that's what I respect they put on
this [ __ ] show do you lock the
entrance in wo-ho Cogan United Center
with Rodman at the height of the Bulls
high limo pulls up backstage United
Senate follow shot Hogan hops out with
the belt wit ride went to sweet they
walk out [ __ ] Jimmy hand voodoo child
playing crowd goes crazy one of the best
swap out ever the Muhammad was wrestling
yeah yeah yeah Robin if I'm alone to
come along yeah yeah they put on what a
great [ __ ] also Donald Trump down a
job
Trump Donald Trump wonder well he just
got stone-cold yes done he got stunned
and sold the Stone Cold Stunner in a way
weird whack
it was awful he didn't we didn't even
know he was foreshadowing easy one to
take I think it's simple and he's gonna
guide you to it you know you don't
really have to do much yeah paddy is
that doing any job man [ __ ] Donald I
don't think he wanted to lose this
toupee I think it's not a toupee door I
think he grows it out from the back it's
not a 12 round the top yeah why do you
think the rock was able to transition so
in such a different way yeah well even I
mean HoCo can try and he did some stuff
but it was still like yes I mean it
still that's the rock but he's able to I
think he meant it when he said he's the
most electrifying man is his charisma
he's a good actor he's funny like yeah
he's just he was the more dynamic actor
than Hulk Hogan you can't connect I
wasn't I wasn't I wasn't into wrestling
at all but I had some homies back then
with rock was that his height yeah and I
would this is dumb [ __ ] I would grow I
was like but I wasn't watching [ __ ] and
I remember watching the rock talk and
I'm like oh [ __ ] this is thoroughly
entertaining this dude knows how to talk
[ __ ] like fun yeah like his back in the
days man when I see like the Ultimate
Warrior come on I blame freakout no no
I'd freak out I think was they often
warrior but he was incoherent when you
talking okay
showing you here when you're 12 when
you're watching a warrior when you a
grown man you see Dalton more like a kid
you like that's what a grown man the
announcers name the little ball headed
means you know the little yeah yeah you
play straight then about the dumb be
[ __ ] man all right that was always the
the highlight I would use the funny part
yeah he was the highlight of the yeah of
the wrestle WWF yeah back in the days
yeah that I mean that's probably an
underrated part of it is to haven't
journalist play it straight the other
underrated part what I noticed at
WrestleMania
the refs I started watch because I know
I can wipe the match yeah and that's
[ __ ] are doing some crazy
luchador [ __ ] matches the match but is
this ref is uh a black dude kind of bald
head and he is super yeah he's just
super into it like if somebody's getting
slammed he kind of like follows the
slant when he follows the slam with his
eyes
[Laughter]
his whole faces I can't believe and so
the matches he was reffing to arrest I
was just watching him and I had the
people next to me while egg was actually
why ladies a huge wrestling fan end up
linking up with him I mean look at this
red is the best this graph is the real
MVP because he sell it everything yeah
just you know you gotta sell that [ __ ] I
remember when braun strowman suplex big
show off the top you know it's the
craziest [ __ ] ever
the really exploded but then what every
like jump deep like some preempted the
ring exploding before exploded yeah he's
over soda oh but he saw did it he knew
that what he knew that the ring was
gonna explode so did he sport a bit of
helped a bit I think he helped it cuz
yeah you got a look at it closely to see
that he jumped before him right I think
he helped it he made it seem like it was
so violent yeah it was crazy
it was like it's like oh I look like a
bomb went off crazy
that's funny bad like we don't read are
important we don't really talk about
wrestling that much on this podcast but
the last time we did we got so much hype
for it really a lot of people were like
a holy thing oh my god I was like man
wrestling is still like grown men no we
went away from it we're like [ __ ] it
this is it
I don't I'm into my relations I'm not
against back to I love it I'm not
against there is no theater man little
son this is pretty much the end of the
episode after this it gets really weird
and like is some terrible music that we
made which I guess it subjective it
depends on whatever I'm just letting you
know if you wanna bail to bail right
here if you do stay after this is your
fault
alright
bring that theremin what oh yeah I'm not
used to that when I was like right you
guys want to ride this out with a beater
or what what's going on here
you got spit bars you guys got bars with
their twin bars twin bars will you spit
one and then you complete the line can
we do that I wish we had that a baby I
think you did
let's bring it out I'm sorry I don't
want to pressure you Hannibal do his
thing front um they may be here inspire
us
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
spread thirsty Fred Fred Fred thirsty
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah do we do it do we do good one
is great
[Music]